Hello,
everybody!
Hello, hello!
I have a cool new overlay now.
Huge shoutout to the person who did my Apex overlay as well.
I'm sorry if I pronounced your name wrong.
Artatee... Art... Art... Art... Art... Art... I'm sorry.
I'm tired.
Art... Artatee... Artatee!
Artatee!
Thank you!
I think I played, like, almost 20 hours of Marvel Rivals the last two days on stream.
My brain is, like, mush right now.
It's fucking...
You know how SK fucking was like, I'm gonna head to bed?
I found out she kept playing Marvel Rivals.
Fucking liar.
She... She... She's also in too deep.
She's...
She has it worse than me.
There's no saving us.
There's no fucking saving us.
She... She's in too deep.
She kept going.
And then she was like... And I was, like, in her... I was watching her stream.
And I was like... And then she was like, maybe I'll stop queuing.
And I was like, no, keep going.
You could be... Because she got to top...
Okay, and then the thing is, the most fucked up part is that she got good lobbies right after I left.
Like, all her lobbies were, like, good tanks, good DPS, good support players.
Like... And I'm like, what the fuck?
Am I the problem?
I was like, what the fuck?
And then she got that three times in a row.
Three times in a row with good lobbies.
Like, no one trolling.
No one doing 2-2.
Everybody doing 2-2-2.
Everyone being good at their roles.
And then she got to top, like... And then she got, like, ranked 335 or some shit.
And in my head, I was just like...
What?
She won three games back-to-back.
And I'm just like, where was my three games?
Where the fuck was... Where the fuck were my three games?
I needed those three games!
Where the fuck was it?
Where...
So,
and then she was like, I'm gonna stop here at rank 300-something.
And I was like, in her chat, I was like, no.
Because if you win one more game, you'll be top 200, SK.
You should keep going.
And then she kept going.
And then she lost.
And then my job here was done.
Curse of Doki.
You're evil.
And that's how you do... And then she ended on a loss.
Everyone must suffer.
Anyway, we hit 800k subscribers!
And we're celebrating it with Guerrilla Marvel Rivals Ranked Stream.
As we should.
You know what?
As it should be.
Let's hope.
Guys, alright, so we need four games.
We just need four games.
If we're lucky, we might be able to win four back-to-back-to-back games.
If Shortfur doesn't decide to go fucking Wolverine and our team...
Oh yeah, or like, I don't know.
And then, I don't know, they're gonna ban characters.
As long as they don't ban, like, characters that, like...
No, he's, like, versatile.
He can play anything, honestly.
But we just need four games.
Guys, was it three games yesterday?
Well, the thing is, I don't know if you guys know this.
But people are climbing rank when I go to bed.
So, it's not like I go to bed and everything just stops.
Because we're not in the Matrix.
Like, I'm the main character and I go to sleep and everyone just pauses.
Or something.
So, yes, now it's four games.
Because people kept ranking up.
So, the cut-off is now Diamond 2.
So, we just need to make it to Diamond 2 right now.
We just need to beat Diamond 2.
And things will be okay.
And then, if we're lucky, it'll be back to back to back to...
Guys, if we don't get Top 500 today, you know what's gonna happen to God of War.
You fucking know what's gonna happen to God of War.
And then, if we don't get it there, I'm gonna cancel God of War.
I'm gonna get in 3D at the concert and play Marvel Rivals.
I will fucking play Marvel Rivals at the concert if we don't get Top 500, guys.
I swear to fucking God.
I'll be like, there's no concert, guys.
I'm gonna be playing Marvel.
I'm taking you all hostage.
I'm taking all of you hostage with me.
We have to get Top 500 today, chat.
We...
I don't care.
Next, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi, Doki.
Congratulations for the 800k.
Hope you have a great day.
I wanted to thank you again for putting my dumb art in the thumbnail.
Wish you good luck for the 14th.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
We actually had a different art for it on the thumbnail.
But then luckily, when I woke up, you posted that artwork.
And then I instantly messaged my thumbnail maker.
And I was like, change it, please.
Okay, I didn't say change it.
But I was like, can we use this?
I was much more polite.
I was like, oh, can we swap it to this artwork instead?
But yes, we're celebrating 800k by playing Marvel Rivals Rink.
I do have something very special planned for the 800k milestone.
But I didn't think we were going to hit it that fast.
I don't know how the fuck I got 2k subscribers when all I've been doing is playing Marvel Rivals.
Like, I was not doing anything special.
I was literally just no-lifing Marvel Rivals for 20 plus hours.
So like, I don't know how the fuck we managed to get 2k within two days from that.
But...
I ain't complaining.
I'm not going to complain.
But yes, I'm so proud of all of you guys for helping me get this far.
Let's hope we can get 1 million by next year, by the end of 2025.
1 million by the end of 2025.
That's our goal for next year.
But yes, thank you guys so much.
I want to be more mushy right now.
I really, really want to be more mushy about the 800k.
But it's grinding hours.
We'll be mushy later.
I need to lock the fuck in, guys.
We need to get out of the fucking trenches right now.
Alright, we're going to do a quick play.
Just to warm up.
We'll be mushy.
Guys, I promise.
I'll be mushy later.
I need to lock in right now.
I need to get this over with.
Like, please.
I can't keep doing this.
I will literally play Marble Rivals at the concert and we don't get top 500.
I'm going to connect the PC to the broadcast and be like, it's Marble Rivals time.
You know what, let's play Mantis.
Let's practice Mantis.
This is quick play anyway.
This is a quick match.
Don't, Toki.
Don't.
No, don't say that, guys.
No, guys, don't say that.
Also, the reason why we're this early is because I don't know why Marble Rivals hasn't sponsored me yet.
I'm saying yet because I'm hopeful that they realize I exist again.
Like, oh my god, they noticed my existence during Alpha and Beta.
I think it's because there's Twitch drops for Marble Rivals on Twitch.
And like, I'm not streaming it on Twitch.
So that's why they're like...
I think they mostly sponsored all the Twitch people because there is Twitch drops.
I know I should be streaming it on Twitch, but I want to document my top 500 journey on YouTube.
So that's why I'm on YouTube.
But I think for future rank climbs, I might...
Because a lot of the rank climbs I'm going to do after this will be very impromptu.
So it'll be very sporadic and random.
If I want to do it on stream...
And most likely, if I want to do it on stream in the future after this, it'll mostly be on Twitch.
Mostly.
Some of them might be on...
I might do some of them on...
Oh my god.
Guys, shoot this!
Shoot this!
It's not that difficult!
Oh my god.
Guys.
Am I the only support?
Oh, yes I am.
Oh my god, I didn't even realize.
Wait, I'm the only support.
Okay, Mantis is not good for solo support.
Okay, I guess...
Back to the Luna life I go.
I didn't realize I was the only support.
I...
I didn't realize.
Back to the...
If I knew, I would not have fucking played how I played.
But at least...
Bitch.
I'm so bad at playing rank.
Oh yeah, you can't...
Oh my god, you're so bad.
You had higher DPS than me.
Oh my god.
Oh wait, did I...
Okay, no, I just joined it.
Alright, what rank am I?
I am Diamond 3 right now.
It's fine, it's quick play.
I...
This is just warming up my mechanical.
So like, I don't care if we lose this one.
Is this...
Literally, that's all she's doing.
She's just DPSing.
That Mantis isn't even healing.
I'm just practicing mechanical stuff because...
Oh yeah, he's definitely practicing too.
Yeah, that Black Panther is definitely practicing too.
These are...
This is not...
You're not Diamond players, that's for sure.
Hahaha.
Yeah, you okay there?
You guys okay?
Woooo.
Yeah, you guys okay?
Bro, I fought actual Black Panther mains, guys.
You okay there, Black Panther?
Do you need help?
You need help?
You need help there?
Oh, I should help them.
Woah!
Dance, everybody!
Dance!
Woooo!
Keep dancing!
Alright, now I leave.
You idiot.
Hahaha.
I have to fight actual ex-pro players.
Get on my level.
Actually know how to play your character.
The game came out three days ago.
They're actually...
Hahaha.
You should know how to play this game after three days.
You should...
Hahaha.
That's okay.
Yeah, that's why I said it.
You should actually know how to play this game.
Alright.
It's actually crazy that this game came out like three to four days ago.
And already people are like so good at it.
It's actually crazy.
Hahaha.
How good people are already.
Yeah, I'm just practicing mechanical.
I'm not like actually focused on healing.
I need to like warm up my...
Fucking...
They sponsored Surefour!
Like if...
Hahaha.
If they can sponsor Surefour, then like...
I'm honestly...
I'm fucking...
I'm like a tamer version of him.
Like...
Come on.
Actually...
Hahaha.
If any...
He said more fucked up shit than I've ever said in my life.
Hahaha.
Like...
On stream.
On stream too.
If anything, I look like I'm on PBS while...
Hahaha.
If anything, if I'm compared to Surefour, I'm literally PBS kids.
This is the day.
Today is the day.
Four games.
This is the day.
We just need...
Four games, guys.
Four...
Four fucking games.
Oh yeah.
I should tell him...
I'm...
I'm R.
To...
To game.
Oh yeah, but...
Yeah, anyway.
That's what I was saying.
Um...
The reason why I'm this early was because of...
I mean, I do...
SK did say she was...
Uh...
Apparently she...
The...
Uh...
The collab with Brian...
Was actually tomorrow, not today.
Because scheduling's hard.
Uh...
And time zones are hard.
Even though, like, we're all in NA.
Uh...
Hahaha.
So, she's down to play whenever too.
But now it's like...
No, I need to get this over with fast.
So, like, I still get to...
I don't have to reschedule my announcement stream.
I mean...
The announcement will still be there.
It's just that instead of doing the other thing that I wanted to do for my announcement stream...
We're just gonna be playing Marvel Rivals.
But, if I get top 500...
You know...
If I get top 500, like...
Okay, we're gonna give it to Spider-Man.
Because he's just gonna be fucking jumping everywhere.
But if I get to...
Get it then...
Then...
Hah...
We can still keep it.
You know?
It's fine.
The Spider-Man deserves to die anyway.
I even hate my own Spider-Man.
Hey, guys.
Heal me.
You better get damaged so I can heal myself.
Okay, I guess not.
What is he shooting at?
Are you okay?
Are you fucking okay?
Like...
Do you need...
Do you need to see an eye doctor?
There's no one there.
Who are the...
Doki...
Bro, he's...
Going through PTSD.
Doki.
Like...
Chill.
Bro, he's...
He's seeing things right now.
He's just like...
He's like...
Oh my god.
There's demons in the walls.
He's fighting his demons.
Yeah, I was just like...
The fuck is he...
Oh my god.
I fucking...
I'm gonna punch a man right now.
Alright, I got him.
I put the healing orb on him because after seeing him shoot a wall, I think he is the most special one that needs it.
The most.
Honestly.
After what I just saw.
Oh shit.
Alright.
Yay!
Dance everybody!
Dance your pain away!
Woooo!
Can't be sad if you're dancing!
Oh my god.
Fuck your stupid Ankh.
Alright.
It's fine.
Okay, we win this and like...
Sure, for us to wait.
Because I lied and was like...
I'm ready.
Because I thought they were gonna win.
Oops.
Alright.
How far is his game left?
I'm gonna check.
I was just like...
Yeah, I'm ready!
Even though I wasn't actually.
I just assumed that he's gonna fucking...
I was gonna lose this one.
So we'll see.
Also like...
Boger.
I heard...
Boger?
Is that his name?
The Overwatch...
Tank player?
Who's now a...
Marvel Rivals...
Tank player?
I'll never understand tank players.
And like...
Their love for tanks.
I'm sorry for any of...
Anyone else...
That like...
Is a tank main.
But I don't understand.
I...
I feel like playing as a tank...
Is just...
Asking to get like...
Cyberbullied in game.
Because like...
You're literally the game's punching bag.
So...
I'm like...
Like I...
I don't know how...
You guys have very...
Very strong mental.
You guys have...
Incredibly strong mental...
To be able to play tank...
Like...
Tank for so long.
And...
Yeah, but like...
Playing support...
I don't get beat up by 200,000 people.
Like...
That's the thing.
I don't get beat up by everybody.
Like, look at this story.
Look at this story.
All...
There were three men on him.
There were so many guys on that guy.
That's crazy.
Oh!
Okay, anyway...
Anyway, as I was saying...
He was like...
Wanting to duo or stack in the future.
And I was like...
Sure, I'm down.
I'm down.
So, potentially...
Potentially, a future collab with him.
After he followed me on Twitter.
See, peer pressure works, guys.
If you...
First off, I can't believe he asked for a collab when he wasn't even following me.
Like...
But...
I peer pressured him into following me.
So like, everything is fine now.
It's fine.
Oh my god.
That was sad for that guy.
See, peer pressure works.
Follow them out and then you get what you want.
Like, woah.
Even though, like, technically he holds a lot of cards.
Like, cause like what?
He's like...
One of the best Dr. Strange players, right?
I'm like, wow.
A free tank?
And I made him follow me?
Let's fucking go.
A free tank duo?
Oh my god.
To make the game easier for me?
But yet...
But yet, I forced him to follow me?
It was like, apparently one of the...
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I live.
Oh my god.
As long as I live, that's all that matters.
I'm sorry.
Oh my god, what?
Yet, I'm making the demands?
The power moves.
Alright.
It's okay.
As long as I don't die to this shark, it's fine.
I actually died by real skill.
I say as the guy just literally just punched me in the death.
Guys, punching is very hard, okay?
Like, do you see those hands?
That shit's scary.
Alright, nice.
You see, the key to getting what you want is just to be very confident.
Even though you know you...
You just fake it till you make it.
Even if you know you don't have the credentials to actually be that confident.
The key is to just...
You know what, fuck this guy.
Fuck this guy.
Oh, you're gonna fucking run?
Oh, you're gonna run?
I'm gonna fucking...
Oh, I'm sorry.
Sorry.
You would not have died if I just stayed there.
I didn't stay there.
The key was that I did not stay there.
That's awkward.
I wanted to chase.
I don't know what to say.
I just really wanted to chase him.
I think, like, he, like, ulted.
He ulted the staircase.
Oh my...
Where?
Oh my god, the Ankh is behind me.
It was that fucker's fault.
He stood next to me.
I was literally there first.
Like, what was wrong with you?
I was literally standing at the point first.
Skate, skate, skate.
There's no way.
Oh, he got off point.
Nice.
Yeah!
We won that.
We won our first fucking...
We won our first quick play.
Alright, let me see how far he is from this game.
Okay, they're still defending.
Okay, this is gonna...
This is gonna take a while.
Oh...
This is a...
Oh, won't play Spider-Man again.
That guy...
I was gonna say, that game was hard.
That game was so chill.
That game was so chill compared to, like, what I had to go through.
Like...
Oh my god.
They're still defending.
Alright, we'll do practice range.
Because if I do another quick play, I feel like...
I feel like...
They'll be done...
They'll be done in the middle of my next quick play.
Try...
We'll look at the practice range.
I hate that...
I hate that, like, they kill so fast.
The Moon Knight...
I wanna be really...
I wanna be good at Mantis.
Her...
Her projectile...
I don't know her speed.
The projectile speed is so weird.
That's, like, my only issue.
This projectile speed is so weird.
That, like, I can't figure it out yet.
Because, like, all the characters have different projectile speed.
So, like, you gotta be, like...
Especially when you're, like...
Luna's projectile speed is different from Mantis's projectile speed.
So...
Like...
It's so hard to figure it out.
Like, it's so hard to transition.
No, it's projectile.
It's not hitscan.
See?
If it's hitscan, it'd be...
It's not hitscan.
I'm pretty sure it's not hitscan.
It feels like projectile.
Yeah, see?
If it was hitscan, this would be instant.
This is projectile.
Yeah, Luna...
Luna...
Oh, yeah, Luna.
No, Luna's hitscan.
Luna's hitscan.
I feel very comfortable on Luna.
Because she is hitscan.
See?
So, like...
This is...
Hitscan is, like...
This is instant.
That's why it's so easy to aim with her.
Because...
It's instant and, like, there's barely falloff.
Dammit.
Falloff, in general...
There's no falloff.
So, that's instant.
But then...
Mantis, you should see that there's a delay.
So, like...
It fucks with me because I play Luna.
And then...
I play Luna...
So, when I swap from Luna to Mantis...
My aim is, like, already on hitscan mode.
And I've always been really bad at projectiles.
So, it's like...
I hate it.
It's so difficult.
Yeah.
There's, like, the delay.
I hate the delay.
I fucking hate projectile.
And there's, like...
I think Cloak is just...
Cloak and Dagger is just...
Left click.
I don't have to worry.
Let's see.
This is also projectile, but, like...
It's not that bad.
Because, like...
I feel like as Cloak and Dagger...
You're not focused on DPS.
As Cloak and Dagger.
Because their heals are, like...
Like, not on...
Not on Dagger.
Mostly on Cloak, if you wanna do DPS.
Because it's just easier.
But...
I think, like...
For Cloak and...
For Dagger...
If you're on Dagger, it's mostly focused on the heals.
And then, if you really wanna do DPS...
You just swap to Cloak.
I don't like playing Loki.
I think, like, he's so situational.
Now...
Loki was so strong in Beta and Alpha.
But they nerfed him so much.
His DPS was so good.
I think if you like playing DPS healer...
Then you go Loki.
But even then, I think...
Mantis is a stronger Loki.
Because, like, Mantis' DPS is, like...
So good.
I don't know exactly...
Like, I don't know.
I feel like...
The only reason I'd say you go Loki...
Is if they have too many aggression ults.
So you can do this.
So you can block all the aggression ults...
Without having to use an ult.
And then, his ult is an extra.
And then, his ult...
If you wanna use it as a defense or aggression...
That's all I could think.
Like, it's his clones and...
But I feel like...
He's, like...
I feel like Mantis is just a better pick.
In general.
Instead of just Loki.
Because, like, you're compensating for the lack of heals, too.
By playing Loki.
Because he doesn't heal that much.
I feel like his healing output is not that good.
Versus, like...
Versus, like, the others.
I don't know.
I know, like, some people play him in higher elo.
But I feel like Mantis is just a better pick in general.
If I had to pick between...
Yeah, and then Mantis can, like...
Can damage boost.
That's the thing.
Like, I can literally damage boost.
And it's so easy to get...
Get this back.
Like, the damage boost and stuff.
And I know Adam's really strong.
The only one that I know that's not really meta is Jeff.
But, like, Adam's really strong just for the res.
But I don't think he's, like...
He's, like, great in terms of healing output.
You have to have a really good other support to be able to play Adam.
I feel like.
Because then, like, his ult is such a game changer.
But then you have to...
You have to have a really good support partner.
IMO.
Yeah, I know this attack is good.
Like, he's just a DPS healer.
Also.
Yeah, he just has...
He's, like...
A lot of these are just DPS healers.
But to be a DPS healer, you have to have a good main support.
Because Adam's obviously...
I think Adam's a flex support.
Adam and Loki are obviously flex supports.
But, like...
Even so.
You have to be, like, able to...
Aim.
You wanna be a good Adam.
But, like, a lot of the worst part about, like...
Adam.
And Loki.
Is that a lot of really bad Adam and Loki players.
They...
All they do is DPS.
They don't even heal.
So it's so frustrating.
It's, like...
It's really frustrating because...
A lot of bad Adam and Loki players don't fucking heal people.
They just rely on the DPS part.
And to build ult.
And then use the ult to change the game.
So it's, like...
Frustrating to play with these guys.
But then, like...
I can always rely on Amantis to do her job.
But, like...
I can't always rely on...
Wait!
Does Surefour do rank to plat?
HAHAHA!
Sorry.
No, he's gonna...
He's gonna fucking...
No, I feel like he's gonna...
Not me.
If I say anything...
I feel like he's gonna fucking lose on purpose.
So I'd be in this elo.
HAHAHA!
I know I shouldn't be toxic.
No.
Don't.
We can't have any curses, guys.
We...
HAHAHA!
We can't have any fucking curses, chat.
Oh!
No Curse of Ra!
HAHAHA!
Guys.
That's good that he's plat.
It's good that he's plat, chat.
Because, like...
With him being plat...
That means we don't have hero bans yet.
We don't need to have hero bans.
HAHAHA!
Guys, don't...
Guys...
HAHAHA!
Guys, don't do this to me, guys.
We need to get out of this fucking garage again, man.
We can't go back to the circus, guys.
We can't go back to the circus, chat.
I'm tired.
I'm so tired of the circus.
Please.
I don't know why I'm streaming the game.
I didn't realize the game awards were today.
I feel like today...
I feel like it's been...
I don't know.
I feel like lately the game awards has been...
Has been, like...
Falling off.
More and more.
That, like...
I'm just not as...
I'm not even hyped about...
Like, the only reason to watch the game awards is just for the trailers.
But, like...
Even then, I'm just like...
What is it gonna...
Like, I know, like...
Oh, maybe, like...
World premiere.
But even then, I'm like...
I'm not, like, super...
Like...
Woo!
Game awards!
I know it's just for the ads.
But, like...
I don't know.
I'm not, like, super, like...
Woo!
Game awards!
HAHAHA!
Alright.
He's gotta play Hawkeye now.
Cause that's the last time he's ever gonna play Hawkeye.
Before they ban him and...
Diamond...
This is, like, his last day on Hawkeye.
There's no way he's gonna be allowed to play him after this.
Oh, he's so low.
I'm confident that...
Every game in Diamond after that...
Will...
Okay.
Guys.
You look at me and I look at you!
Nice.
Okay.
He's so low.
Nice.
It's fine.
She's just poking me.
I had to worry about the giant fucking Hulk in front of me first.
Okay.
The Hulk was...
The Hulk in front of me was a lot scarier...
Than anything else behind me.
Wait, did he, like, die already?
Did he got out of his mech already?
That was fast.
Oh, they're planning on...
Okay.
Healing, I'm healing.
I'm keeping everybody alive.
The first ranked game is always, like...
I'm fucking...
I'm waking up still.
I got...
I drank some gamer subs today.
By the way, guys.
Did you guys know?
That I have...
Oh my god!
Bro, okay!
Remember what I did for you!
We lose this game because I did that?
I'll be so sad.
Literally got fucking saved.
God, he needs to be babysit.
He needs to be babysat.
I was like, kill the streamer!
Oh my god, there we go.
We're fine.
By the way, if you use the code DokiBird...
You get 10% on gamer subs.
You get 10% off.
And I've been on...
I've been on some fucking gamer subs.
I've been on a gamer subs grind.
You're gonna be okay.
You're gonna...
Oh!
You know what?
It was the effort.
Nice.
Gonna keep him up first.
Alright!
You think they just notice I'm here?
I like...
Oh no, they notice now!
I like, I was in the backline for so long!
I was in the backline!
It's fine.
I was just like, oh man.
I fucked up because I decided to not be on the backline.
I decided to jump down from high ground.
I've been on gamer subs this entire Marvel Rivals grind.
Just to like, lock in and stay awake.
That's why I've been like, able to function.
Back to back.
Literally the only reason I'm able to function right now.
Sorry.
I shouldn't laugh at that.
It's like, we need to win this game.
That was funny though.
Gotta admit.
That was pretty funny.
Well, I just drink one...
I just drink one cup of gamer subs.
In the morning.
That's really it.
It's not like I chug it down.
I just drink like, one cup.
And then like, for the entire stream.
And then like, that's how I fu- Like that- Like I just wake up and then get some water.
And then later on, get some...
Jesus Chri- The wall!
I can't save that!
Like, I would love to be able to save you from that.
But like, that was just way too much damage.
That was too much damage!
Yeah, I use my cups.
Oh...
He's down there.
So we should be fine.
Okay, he died.
He died.
I thought I would be fine, but then...
And I'm not being fine.
Jesus Christ.
I think we only have one fight left.
They're actually doing so much just to...
Just to kill us.
Oh, one archer boy.
Okay, I'm on point now too.
Both supports are on point.
Alright.
We have no supports though, so that's bad.
Oh my god, get on point.
Get on point.
Get on point, please.
We're coming back.
The supports are coming in!
Oh no.
No, get on point, Captain America.
Get on point.
We can save you if you get on point.
Just...
No!
That was so close.
It's fine.
It's okay.
This game will be different, guys.
This will be a different game.
Oh my god, we had to...
The thing that sucks is that we had to touch the point.
The supports had to.
Because we were the closest, so there was nothing we could do.
I feel like I could've waited a second longer, but I was worried about...
I don't know the overtime ticker.
I don't know how fast the overtime ticker goes.
Like, I don't know.
I don't know how fast I didn't want to take the risk.
I'm locked in.
I'm so fucking locked in.
I was trying to figure out...
Healers.
Good luck.
Good luck, buddy.
We're all okay, right?
Okay.
Alright.
Dancing!
I love to dance!
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god, he's solo too.
That's unlucky.
Fuck you, you stupid ninja.
You think you're better than me?
Grab it on the other support.
Okay.
I feel like I should put it on Captain America right now.
Until... Okay, nevermind.
Now he's here.
Because like, Traverse is gonna die non-stop.
You're so healthy.
Oh, we did not...
We gotta get the Bruce Banner.
Nice, we got him.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, Captain!
You're crazy!
Captain America!
Oh, fucking he's dead.
Oh, he's so dead.
He's so fucking dead.
I think he's gonna come down from here, right?
He hulked out.
Okay, so I'll heal him.
You're fine.
You're fine, you're so fine.
You're so fine.
I don't feel fine no more.
I feel fine again.
I am so healthy.
We're dancing!
Cause we're dancing!
Dance your pain away!
You'll eventually get top 500 Toki if you just keep dancing!
Oh my god.
Yeah, why would fucking Captain America just punch?
Just throw your shield.
Throwing your shield should not be a fucking cooldown.
Just fucking throw it.
Like, does his arm get fucking tired?
Like, what's wrong with his arm?
You're a fucking super soldier.
What's wrong with you?
He's all Doki.
He's like 90.
Being 90 does not mean you can't stop knowing how to throw a fucking shield.
You're literally Captain America.
Yeah, and what did he do in those wards?
He fucking threw his shield.
What was it?
Oh wait, you're right.
Isn't like Wolverine like technically 120?
Yeah, if Wolverine can fucking- Oh my god.
Why?
Okay.
That's fucked.
Yeah, I don't think we won the first fight.
They literally engage with- They engage with that.
Yeah, but Captain America has super soldier serum.
It's almost the same thing.
This is very risky, but I trust the hella to not be able to kill me.
That's the only reason why I'm like looking- peeking it.
I'm like, there's no way.
Oh my god.
Oh, I know.
Don't kill me after I said that.
Don't kill me after I said I trust on you to not be able to kill me.
That would be so embarrassing.
Oh my god, she almost killed me.
She actually almost killed me.
Oh please, Captain America.
You're making me very nervous right now.
Stand in a line.
Oh my god, stand in a fucking line.
Oh, Mr. America.
Mr. America.
Please, please.
Please.
Just stand.
Just stand in here.
It's fine.
Oh, we didn't kill Bruce Banner though.
Oh my god.
There's too many things on my screen.
Oh my god, Captain America, please just die on point.
Captain America, no!
Live!
And that's how you play a healer.
Oh, this is scary.
Get away.
Literally, I have to babysit him so he'd fucking live.
Everybody wants to fucking kill him.
I feel like we have to put so many resources on him.
There were three people on him.
I did not care about anybody else.
There was the fucking entire country on him.
That's actually crazy.
Like, he's gonna jump.
Watch this.
He's gonna jump on him.
Oh, shit.
Oh my god, he didn't jump on him.
He didn't jump on him this time.
For once.
For once he just jumped on Rocket Raccoon, thank fucking god.
Come on.
Okay, there you go.
Come on, guys.
Maybe you guys can kill something.
Nice.
Nice, we did it!
That's how it feels.
Like being a healer.
Oh my god.
We did it.
Oh, we fucking did it.
Jesus Christ.
I literally saw four people just trying to beat him up.
Oh my god.
Three games, chat.
Three fucking games.
Three more.
And then...
Oh, is he diamond?
He must be diamond now, right?
Oh, now they're just gonna ban Hawkeye.
I don't know what the fuck he's gonna...
They're gonna ban Hawkeye now.
Three games away.
Just three, right?
Just three?
And only three.
No more...
Won't have to worry.
It's just three.
Oh, please.
Please just be...
Oh, wait.
Somebody's plat.
There's no hero bans.
Oh my god, thank god.
Another day without a hero ban.
Alright, I'm gonna use the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
Okay.
I'm ready.
I'm so ready.
Three more.
Three more games.
What's the worst that could happen?
I say as we start losing.
Alright,
here we go.
Guys, just because I'm not sponsored and Surefire is sponsored, don't buy the battle.
Surefire told you guys to buy the battle.
Don't buy the battle until I'm sponsored.
Oh my god.
That's scary.
He just died.
Just like that.
I'm learning how to play cover now.
What's lucky is that the tank's also taking damage, so I don't have to worry about healing him when he's doing that fucking shit.
So like, he gets all these heals.
I'm making sure that he's also being healed enough.
Please, please, please be okay guys.
I froze him, but he's coming back to life, that fucking bitch.
I know where he is, because there's no way he moved.
Oh my god.
I need to play cover more now.
No!
Just stand here and just start dancing!
Just, just start dancing!
Just start dancing!
Alright, so, they have like a million other ults to be worried about.
Oh, that's our portal.
Oh my god, no!
It freaked out!
I saw that and I freaked out because I was like, what the fuck is that doing there?
Oh shit, oh.
Fine, I'll just win it.
Oh my god, again!
Again!
Nice.
Oh my god, our Bucky popped the fuck off.
Alright, sorry Tier 4, I'm going to give it to Bucky now.
Alright.
Sorry.
Sorry, he deserves this more.
He coked.
The fuck you carry?
Sorry dude.
Only good little aces get the little, get the fucking heal orb.
He did, he did okay.
He did his job, but the Bucky, he like, he did his job and then he, and then he worked overtime.
The Bucky stayed for overtime.
Sure, if we're clocked in and clocked out.
What?
Oh my god, it's like a little fucking ramp.
It's like a race car.
He's employee of the month.
Yeah, the Bucky's employee of the month.
You gotta reward the employee of the month.
Yeah, he did three overtime, which is my favorite too.
Oh, hello time.
Oh, what?
He actually went for me?
What is our Doctor Strange blocking?
You would think he'd block for me.
Like, where was he blocking?
I was so confused.
Oh, goodbye Groot.
Oh, he's so dead.
Like, I don't know where the fuck he is.
Alright.
They had ult advantage there, but they used one ult?
Two ults?
I don't even know how many ults they used.
Alright, I'll give it back to him.
Maybe he'll start performing better.
I did not mean that to be...
Sorry, I meant like, you know what I mean.
Sorry, Marble Rivals makes me a really fucked up person.
I'm sorry.
Are you serious?
I instant died?
Oh my god, I couldn't even press Q when he did that.
I couldn't even press Q!
I just like, instantly died.
Alright, nevermind.
I'll put it back on him.
I'm a little worried though, because they do have a Hawkeye too.
So I'm trying not to...
We're in this way?
Okay.
Alright, Groot.
I'm Groot.
I can't see anything.
There's just trees everywhere.
There's literally just trees everywhere.
Where do I look at?
Oh, he's one.
They built an entire apartment down here?
Dude, the Groot maze.
There was like five, like six different walls from both sides, Groots.
I am Groot.
Alright, now I've learned.
Okay.
Nice.
No!
There's a Hanzo right there!
There's a Hanzo!
I like how they made a fucking ramp just to kill him.
I'm heading over.
I'm fucking running.
I'm running.
Okay.
Gotta make sure the orb's on him.
Oh my god.
I think he's...
Oh my god, how do you save him?
There was no saving him.
He got walled off by our own Groot that couldn't even heal him.
Our own Groot walled him off on the other side.
Did you guys see that?
Alright.
No point.
I can't touch it.
He got left behind.
Okay, he's gonna go penny.
Yeah, that's a better idea.
At least we don't have to worry about him getting walled off.
Yeah, he wasn't able to do anything this time.
The Bucky, cause the... I don't know, me having an orb on the...
The Bucky would help him survive getting dived.
I don't think he's getting dived at all.
Honestly.
I think his positioning is so hard for the healers to heal him though.
So I don't know, cause I have to choose between him or Turf War, but they both position themselves so weird from the healers.
Unless I play high ground with them.
I might have to play with one of them.
I don't know.
I need to figure out how to position myself, I guess.
I hate this.
I hate all these fucking trees.
And then not to worry about the building blocking me.
Guys, guys, trees are blocking.
Okay.
Whoa, whoa, that group blocked the wall.
That group wall fucking saved him.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
It's fine.
I'm just gonna stand here.
Yeah, this side, this doesn't have an angle with the Anzu.
What?!
I pressed Q!
Wait, I got stunned?!
Oh my god!
I pressed Q!
I got stunned!
I instantly hit Q the moment I heard I.
I heard I.
Oh, it's not a line?
Okay, I'll figure it, fix that.
And yeah, I'll just get rid of it cause I don't think I can fix it.
Okay.
I'm just gonna do this now.
I don't know.
Cause I'm like...
Just hoping we get a kill.
Oh, stand down.
Again?
He's one.
Nice.
Yeah, that's good.
What?!
He almost died from that!
Okay, we heal each other.
Okay.
I think the only thing I'm worried about is just...
Fucking crazy, that guy was...
Live!
Yes!
Two more games.
Two more fucking games.
Two more!
Two more fucking games!
And then we'll be free!
Oh my god!
We're almost there!
Okay, I can see the... I can see the finish line.
Oh my god!
Oh, is my... I fucking... I don't... Oh my god, maybe the curse was the aimbot eye all along.
That was the curse all along.
Alright, since it's not aligned, I'm too lazy to fix it.
Alright.
Oh...
What are we banning, guys?
Hella?
I'm gonna request hella.
What?
Who said that?
Took my RR twice?
Yo, he took my... What's RR?
What's RR?
What does RR mean?
Oh, rank points?
Alright, well, apparently this guy lost 10 games in a row, so I know who to avoid.
Like, rank roints?
Oh my god.
Alright, Road Aggie, did I take your rank roints?
No,
my rank roints.
Guys, like, what the fuck is RR?
Is that what they call it in fucking Viral Rivals?
What the fuck else would it stand for?
Like, what the fuck else would RR stand for?
My rank roints?
No!
Rank raiding?
Bro, what the fuck?
I'm sorry, Valiant.
That's a dumb thing, rank raiding.
Has he ever played tank?
I'm just gonna stand here.
You guys can tell, like, the higher elo you are, the more safe I have to play now.
Like, I just have to play angles.
I'm not going high ground because I know they have a Hawkeye, but like, I'm not playing angles because of it.
I got Roll.
Got my rank roints.
My position has changed a lot the higher elo I am in.
Because, like, I know when I'm in the lower elos, I'm like, they can't do jack shit.
You know?
You're like, I can stand here.
Like, they can't fucking kill me.
But I'm like, oh shit, these guys can aim now.
Yeah.
These guys can fucking aim.
I don't want to get randomly Hanzo, like, logged.
Or Hawkeye logged.
Yeah.
Like, one shot?
I'm like, I'm not getting one shot.
I'm like, playing here.
I don't have to be center stage.
Would you give up arm?
Hey Scooby, would you give up rank roints for a Scooby snack?
I'm going to start calling it rank roints now.
No, my rank roints.
Not my rank roints.
Okay, that's sad.
That's sad.
Okay.
Nice bullseye, bro.
I can't see you!
Oh!
No!
I have to- I have to get out of cover!
I'll be fine.
I'm just assuming if- oh.
Is he okay?
See?
He's fine for now.
I didn't want to- I didn't ult there because, like, I felt like there's no reason to.
Okay, I'm ulting now.
So we can stabilize this.
Last fight.
It is last fight, though.
I was hoping to get a kill, but they didn't.
At least I didn't get a kill.
Oh my god.
We did it!
That was a good hold.
That was a really good hold.
At stand.
Did this guy advertise his fucking TikTok?
Who did he play?
This guy advertises his fucking TikTok.
Oh my god.
Alright, buddy.
Oh my god, guys.
I'm gonna get- Oh my god, guys.
I'm gonna get my rank points.
On my rank points.
Oh my god.
This is better than any Scooby snack.
I gotta respect the hustle.
Hustle, yeah.
But on fucking TikTok.
You'd think, you know, you'd think it'd be Twitch, but fucking TikTok.
I'm getting points for my TikTok.
My Rickrock.
Apparently, apparently it means like rank.
What was it?
I don't even remember the original.
What was it for Valorant?
Rank something?
I don't even know.
I just know rank points.
Rank rating.
Oh yeah.
See, it doesn't even roll off your tongue.
That's the thing.
It doesn't fucking roll off your tongue, so it's like- That's why I think it's a dumb way to say your competitive rank.
This is good for- I think- Oh my god.
She's so good for defense, though.
It's actually so annoying.
This is annoying for defense.
There's so much healing.
I think this positioning is good.
So I don't have to worry about the Hawkeye.
Now we have Hawkeye and Widow?
Okay, buddy.
We have double Sniper, but I don't know if double Sniper is supposed to be good.
Yeah, I'll do it after.
No!
I landed it!
Rocket, please!
Just hit me once!
I didn't have my shift.
I already used it.
That's why I didn't- I couldn't heal myself.
I don't want to use it aggressively because- I don't want to use my ult aggressively because they have too many- There's too many stuff to worry about.
Use this so I can heal them after the Megiddo.
The
fuck?
How did he die so fast?
It's fine.
Yay!
Got my Rain Coins.
Let's go!
Oh my god.
Is that it?
Oh my- Is this it?
I need- Oh my god.
23.
One more game.
One more game, guys.
Just need one more.
Also, like, I realized, like, 3 seconds in I was on damage.
Because, like, sometimes when I press Q, I spam Q so it goes to damage.
I need that UI to be bigger.
Like, it's so hard to, like- That UI is so, like, hard to know when you're on damage or heal instantly.
Because, like, it looks so similar.
It looks so fucking similar.
Similar!
Yeah, but it's just a little bigger.
It's literally just a little tiny bigger.
So, I'm like- I need it to, like- I need it to be more similar.
Oh my god.
Oh, wait.
Is this a plat lobby?
I think it's a plat lobby because...
We can just pick.
There are different colors, but it just- When you're on damage, it goes up a little bit.
That's the thing.
So, it's so similar in general.
Like, so, like- Because you see both of them.
I feel like- Just cancel out the other one.
So you don't see the audio thing for the damage, I feel like.
I feel like as long as you don't see the audio thing for the damage, then it'll be fine.
I just don't like the fact that it looks too- Like, it's just- My mind doesn't instantly- Also, I don't know.
Maybe it's because, like, I still need more hours to get used to it.
But, like, I'm not used to, like, just clicking.
I'm not- I just need it to look more different.
Because I instantly think I'm on heal.
Alright, one game.
One more game.
Oh my god, it's Magneto time.
Alright, this is the game.
Why are you standing here for your portal?
You could've stood anywhere else!
Else!
That's good that they're just looking at him.
Literally me healing him is healing Surefour, so that's fine.
Like, I'll take that.
Like, him feeding lets me heal Surefour, so that's fine.
What?
Like, why the fuck did he stand in front of the Punisher?
No.
Like, there they come!
No again?
Maybe you can do something from this.
Push.
We're up.
Jesus Christ.
I have to put so much resource on this guy.
Please kill him!
Holy fuck.
Alright,
don't worry, I can keep both tanks up.
That's fine.
I'm fine with that.
I can keep both the tanks up.
I'm okay with that.
Um, give me a sec.
I can do both tanks.
I can still keep both tanks up.
That's fine.
Jesus Christ, I can't keep- No!
Goodbye, everybody.
That's so much damage!
That was so much damage, holy shit!
They died so fast!
Fuck, I got you.
You guys have got lots of guns.
Yeah, but I meant, like, our team in general.
Like, they died so fast, even with the ult.
Stand in a line.
Stand in a line so I can heal like this.
Hahaha.
Stand in a line.
Jesus Christ.
Alright.
Thank God they stood in line.
Thank God.
Stand in a line!
Oh.
I ain't coming for you.
Okay.
We'll put on the Helidon.
Since we don't have our other tank right now.
I ult.
Okay.
Nice.
Get the fucking- Get the Soldier!
Oh my God.
Alright.
Bye.
Oh!
Whoa!
I ult, though.
That's good.
Bye.
We're so healthy.
Okay.
Are we- Are we okay?
Whoa!
Oh my God, everybody lived, but, like, will we keep living, though?
Oh shit.
Okay.
That's fine.
We got- We got Hella ult.
Beat him up!
Oh!
That's a good push.
That was a good push.
Our Hella was really good.
Thank God.
Thank you to the NRE team for bringing a plat player into this lobby.
Thank you.
Shoutout to that guy for bringing that plat player.
Shoutout to him.
No bans.
I hope we- I hope we win so I can take back the- the rank warrants I gave to Temp.
I restart his Loose Streak.
I wanna restart his Lost Streak.
And he's like, like, I'm on a 10k Lost Streak, guys.
I ain't comming no more.
I wanna be his Gatsby.
Is that fucked?
Is that fucked up?
Necessary toxicity.
Actually evil.
Yeah, I'm Diamond 3.
The cycle of toxicity.
He thought that he broke his Lost Streak, but no, I'm just starting a new line.
Like, the new avatar line.
I'm restarting- I'm starting a new one.
Oh my God, I'm fucking- I'm fucking- I'm sorry.
I have to look- I have to look this way.
Our tank is not doing so well.
Oh no.
Makina, no.
I don't think we're gonna touch that.
No!
That was a really good portal.
Because, like, we were- we had to go a different direction.
That was a really good portal from them.
Because I didn't- I wasn't able to drop down.
Oh no, we're staggered.
No.
No, I- that's karma.
I'm so sorry I didn't mean that.
I'm sorry.
I don't want to get karma'd.
I'm so sorry.
No, he lives?
He actually lives that?
Oh no, guys.
No, I don't want to get karma'd, guys.
I am Groot.
He is Groot.
Yay!
Alright.
Alright, we used both support ults, so- oopsie.
I am Groot.
Alright.
We accidentally used both support ults, so...
What do we do?
Because they have- they have their Dr. Sh- Yeah, and they have this.
And they had this.
And they had this!
There.
I'm not going to live!
Thank you!
It's alright, fine.
Move up, move up.
I am Groot.
He's Brooding.
He's WE ARE GROOT!
Okay.
Oh my god.
I'm not- we're going to have Rocket Raccoon ult before my ult.
Alright.
We are Groot.
Nice.
Oh, I'm so locked in.
I'm so fucking locked in.
What?!
He died so fast!
Nice.
We're pushing!
I'm skating!
Skate!
He's one, he's one, he's actually one!
Nice!
We got him.
Alright.
Oh...
Two more fights, two more fights guys!
Two more fights!
I'm locked.
I am Groot.
I don't like staying up here.
Like, I don't know!
I feel like, oh no.
I'm Brooding.
Go, go, go!
Go!
Okay.
Nice.
Alright, they have...
Okay, they used Strange ult.
They're going to have Bucky ult.
They're going to have Hawkeye ult.
They're going to have...
Oh, they're going to have all their DPS ult.
Alright, good luck everybody.
I'm going to stand back here.
Yes, guys.
But remember how many DPSs they have there?
And they used a tank ult, guys.
That's...
Goodbye, Groot.
Groot.
That's your rez.
That's where your rez went.
Not right here!
Oh my god.
Yes.
Oh no!
I killed...
Oh wait, I got the rez.
Let's go.
Oh, they're boring again too.
No.
Not the arc.
I might get ults from here.
No again!
That's right!
Whoa!
Okay.
That scared me though.
Wait.
Is this it?
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Beat him up!
I'm going to fucking start fissing!
No!
I'm going to start...
Wait.
We're sure for...
Oh no.
I need to be like...
Sure for...
Don't Q!
I can't swap the sure for!
I think...
Don't Q!
Yeah!
Diamond 2!
Screenshot!
Oh my god!
Nice!
Oh my god.
Don't Q.
Don't fucking Q.
I can't message him to say, Don't Q!
Yeah!
Don't Q!
Give me a sec!
Oh my god.
Wait.
Is that it?
How do I check?
47!
No!
I need one more!
I need one more.
I need two more!
I need...
What is it?
Two...
One more win.
No!
Oh my god.
We're so close.
Is it 47?
As in like 47 points?
Or I'm...
I'm...
Or...
Am I like...
547 plays?
Or...
Do I need...
Is it...
Is it 47 players?
Or do I need 47 points?
547?
Okay.
So it's one game.
It's one game.
Okay.
This next game.
I'm ready.
47 people...
47 games.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Just one more.
Oh my god.
One more win.
And then I'll be okay.
I'll be okay.
Oh my god.
I just need...
We're...
Please.
We're so close.
We're so fucking close.
I hope...
I wanna win so I can win with 69 wins.
I just...
I wanna win with 69 wins.
Oh my god.
Please.
Please, RNG.
Guys, we gotta pray.
No, if we do comms, we're not gonna focus.
We do not...
When we both get in voice together, we do not lock in.
We 100% do not lock in.
Comms is actually like...
A deep puff for us.
Oh my god.
Guys, give us your...
Pray and give us energy, guys.
We're so close.
We're almost there.
What the fuck?
Thanos Wang?
That's a good name.
Oh my god.
I hope we're lucky, guys.
I hope we're lucky.
I hope we can be lucky.
We just need to be lucky.
I'm nervous.
I'm so nervous.
There's no plat players in here.
There's a grandmaster?!
Bro, why does he have a master?!
Oh my god.
A grandmaster blocks my path.
Oh my god, they have clone man too.
Who's a tank player.
I have Phreak's and...
Is that Muffin?
The tank player?
Muffin?
Oh my god.
I have to...
They're guarding the top 500.
They're guarding it right now.
That's my raid boss, chat.
That's my fucking raid boss.
I think they have...
Pay attention, sorry man.
Oh my god.
Don't ban Hella, because that character is corny.
I mean, that's a pretty solid thought, actually.
Spider-man?
What the hell?
Who the fuck plays Spider-man on our team?
That's an interesting one.
Who's the Spider-man player?
So what are we thinking, guys?
They have a Star-Lord one trick, I know.
He's rank 41?!
Oh shit, which one's super?
Oh, is it...
Oh, is it Raring Garlic?
Is that super?
Okay.
Bro, what the fuck does that...
Oh my god.
Why do we have the hardest lobby for the top 500?
What the fuck?
Do you tank player, or like...
We have to play against...
Oh my god.
This actually is like...
Of course, my top 500 game has to be like...
The hardest game.
Oh my god.
Both teams are stacked...
As fuck.
Okay.
Hey, can you hear me?
Yeah, what's up man?
How's it going?
What's your problem, huh?
I'm just a little guy, you know?
It's fine.
I was just being a chilled guy, but then I got attacked.
Oh my god, this is an overwatch versus overwatch.
Oh my god.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, I'm actually on full focus.
I'm not gonna look at chat, guys, for this game.
I actually have to pay attention.
He's good iffy.
I'll bring out the pocket pick Magneto.
I don't want to...
Magneto.
Dude, my Magneto is insane.
Sidelocked half.
Good hook, good hook.
I can bubble you here if you want to do it, bro.
Sidelocked.
Invade.
Careful, you guys are up.
We can't help you.
I think we're fine.
No, I'm just getting Iron Man in the back, so I gotta heal.
Iron Man's hook is so broken.
Well, we also banned Elis.
You know?
Yeah.
Stop him, stop him, stop him.
Maximum buff!
Nice.
Still got the fucking Hulk on the right.
He's in baby form.
Sidelocked dead.
Okay.
Iron Man's half.
Why?
Why, Adam?
Oh my god.
Hulk on the right there.
Manta's in the back.
I saw Manta in the back there.
There's still Hulk, I think.
Hold on.
We're dead.
Okay.
Oh my god.
No!
Luna, Manta's dead on me.
Both of you are dead.
I traded with Iron Man.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I used it.
Oh, I don't think so.
Okay.
This is like, I'm super locked in right now.
Maximum punch!
Shit!
Wow, that's crazy!
I have to run.
I'm dead, I'm dead.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I think I have to get some voice comms.
To be like, please heal me.
What condition is this?
I have to re-bind my voice comms though, that's the thing.
I can't do it now.
Luke's pocketed.
I'm gonna wait.
Maximum punch!
Oh no!
I wasted it too.
Oh, I didn't think I'd get hit by that.
Fuck!
I didn't think I'd get hit by his ult.
I didn't think he'd be on me too.
That sucked.
I didn't think I'd get hit.
I'm dead.
I'm walking.
I had to keep the tank up, but I sacrificed my life for it.
I'm not coming back now.
It's just, uh, Sylas, Banner, and, uh...
Right there.
So I'm just living up to what I'm doing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Stabilize.
I have ult, I have ult, I have ult.
Yay, I have ult too.
Me and the Brawl?
I mean...
You don't have it?
Oh my god.
They all die so fast.
He didn't stun them!
Oh my god.
That game was so intense.
Get ready to shield me.
When we go in, I'm gonna ult.
Okay.
I could fly in with you.
You're gonna fly ult.
Or I could TP, I could TP.
You wanna do a TP quick?
No, I'm just behind them already.
I'm just gonna fly in and ult.
Get ready to push.
I'm ready, I'm ready.
Nice.
Are we alive?
Shit.
We can't help you.
Tank is about to ult behind us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Fly.
Or fly.
Standing alive, standing alive!
Everybody standing alive!
No way.
Oh my god.
I wanna stabilize here.
I'm gonna just stabilize.
I'm gonna silence them.
Do you have bubble, Magneto?
Just checking.
Okay, I'm ready.
Alright, I have bubble.
Alright, I'm going up.
Bubble.
Nice!
That's our team up!
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm gonna rebun.
I'm gonna rebun.
Heal is ticked.
I mean, Hela's banned.
They have Iron Man and the magic, so...
Yeah, she's pretty good against Iron Man.
Oh my god.
I just have to communicate.
Okay.
Oh!
Ah!
This is a scary game.
Against a Grandmaster, yeah.
We're playing against a Grandmaster.
Oh my god.
This is...
This is actually Raid Boss Hours.
It's like...
Oh my god, it's Raid Boss Hours.
Right here.
Of course, this has to be my last game.
This game is like...
It could be my last game.
Oh my god.
This game is intense.
This brings me back to Overwatch days.
Peak Overwatch days in Top 500.
Oh!
Okay.
Oh my god!
I'm getting hard fo- I'm sorry.
That's crazy.
I'm coming back.
I'm skating.
I'm gonna skate.
I'm putting it on tank.
No!
Oh my god, this Ironman is crazy!
This Ironman is insane!
Holy shit.
Yeah, he's so good on the right with the right person.
It's actually so scary.
I don't know how to play...
I don't know how to play safe when we're attacking.
Wait, is this the best Scarlet Witch NA?
Oh yeah.
Okay.
I'd be the only one.
Wait, there's Scarlet Witch players in NA?
I'm one out of one.
I'm getting really sweaty right now.
I'm liking what you're picking up right now.
I'm liking it.
See if anyone walks in the portal.
Okay.
They all just turned around.
You mind-controlled them.
That's fine.
Anything goes for me.
He's frozen.
Oh my god, no!
Oh my god!
We got divided by Hulk!
I want to use my ult, but it's...
It's never a good situation to use it.
I'll put it on the other tank.
He's frozen, she's frozen!
Oh my god.
Alright, I'm going up.
Hulk is red!
Hulk one, Hulk one!
Nice.
Oh my god.
I don't even know if my mic is working.
I don't know.
I don't know if my mic is even working.
I'll put it on the other tank.
Yo, that was so intimidating.
Thank god.
I'm using attack.
Damage boosting.
No, I'm getting active.
I'm getting Grooted.
No, not the Groot!
No!
Where was I?
Mantis ult!
Oh.
Was she holding me?
I think we can just Luna ult.
I think we can just Mantis ult with my ult and bubble.
And I think that's GG enough.
You got bubble?
I'm dead, no Mantis ult.
You have Luna ult though, you have Luna ult.
Nice.
She has no ult.
I'm on damage, I'm on damage.
Oh.
I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
Come back, come back.
Come on, come on.
This side.
Starlord, Starlord.
He's low, he's low.
Oh, nice.
GG.
Oh my god, is that it?
Is that it?
Oh my god.
Did we do it?
Is it over?
I don't know.
Oh my god.
I out-healed the other Luna.
Fuck you.
I out-healed the other Luna and I had more accuracy and I did more damage.
Fuck you, bitch.
Is that it?
Yes!
Guys, we
did it.
Oh my god.
I feed a Grandmaster to get here.
I literally feed a Grandmaster to get my elo.
And I played so well.
I played so fucking well.
Wait.
GGs.
I had to do some work.
Thank you for the game.
I'm calling it here.
Ending on good luck.
Good luck with your games.
Oh my god!
Guys!
800k subscribers!
And top 500!
Screenshot, screenshot.
Remember to take a screenshot.
Wait, wait, wait.
Let me pose myself.
Let me pose myself, everybody.
Before you take the screenshot.
You shout out to Surefort and SK for playing with me.
I really appreciate it.
And wanted to...
That's me!
Remember to put a pointing image over there.
I'm top 500 in the world!
Guys, I need you guys to know this is the world leaderboards.
So, like, this is everywhere around the world.
And I did it.
And I won the most stacked lobby ever.
On both sides.
There were so many good players on both teams.
And I beat a fucking grandmaster rank 47 gamer.
Oh my god.
And I played.
I think I played really well.
I played really well in that lobby too.
So it's not like I was getting carried or anything.
I did my job.
I kept everybody alive.
And I positioned myself pretty well there.
Am I the first VTuber to hit top 500 in Marble Rivals?
Am I the first one?
If not, I'll be the first one in NA.
Oh my god.
We did it, guys!
Okay, we fucking did it.
I'm so...
I'm so happy.
That's me!
Oh my god.
Well, SK here is a fleshy too.
So, like, the pure...
The pure only VTuber.
Like, pure form VTubing.
Oh my god.
My face is so red.
My face is so red and flushed.
But, like, thank you everybody.
Oh my god, thank you guys.
And this is why...
I should have been Gamer of the Year.
I should have been nominated for Gamer of the Year.
This is why.
Oh my god, thank you guys.
Thank you all for the superchats.
And the congratulations.
We were here three very long days.
We won four games.
Back to back to back to back.
We won four games in a row to get here.
And I'm so happy.
I'm really...
I'm really happy.
Wait, I'm gonna take my own screenshot.
I wanna take my own screenshot too, guys.
I wanna also take a screenshot.
Okay.
I'm gonna take a screenshot right here.
That's me.
You guys can take screenshots too, but I'm taking my own as well.
Okay, and then I'm gonna take...
Okay, I'm gonna do another screenshot too.
There's another screenshot I wanna take too.
Okay.
I wanna...
I wanna do... use...
Where is it?
Where is my other...
Where is the other one that I wanna use?
Oh my god.
I'm sorry, I'm just so happy, guys.
I'm really, really happy because it took so long, everybody.
It took so long.
But we did it, so I'm like...
So happy, guys.
I'm so fucking happy.
We worked so hard to get here.
And we fucking did it.
Okay, I'm gonna use this one too.
Whoa.
That's me.
I'm gonna take this screenshot too.
Oh my god, look.
Can you see that?
That's me right there.
That's me right there, guys.
Oh my god.
I'm so happy.
Oh my god, and look.
Look at the silly number right here.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, look at that.
And I got it in 69 wins.
Pure cinema.
I'm sorry, I'm just really happy to be able to accomplish that.
I wanna end top 500 for my rivals this season.
But obviously, now that I did it, it's back to the cage now.
It's back to the cage of... to the gamer work cage to finish up all my...
I stalled a lot of my actual work stuff for this.
I'm sorry to my management team, because I get super obsessive when it comes to rank, that I put everything in the backlog.
And I was like, I'm sorry, I need to play rival rivals now.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry to the staff and everything.
Thank you everybody for watching this long 3 day journey to get here.
I'm so happy.
And I'm so happy that you guys were here to watch it.
And the fact that we ended it on the most insane game ever.
The fact that my top 500 game was the sweatiest, high skilled lobby we've ever played so far.
It was crazy.
And I did it all on stream too.
It was the perfect top 500 rank up game.
Thank you everybody.
And thank you all for being here to celebrate my 800k subscribers.
We got 800k.
You got your dragons here.
And we got top 500 today.
In 3 days, we managed to pull it off.
I will try and end top 500 this season.
The future rank streams will most likely be on Twitch now.
If they're just occasional grinding.
If I want to stream it, I'll be streaming it on Twitch.
So check me out on Doki Breed on Twitch.
I might stream some on YouTube.
But only if it's scheduled.
But if I just want to play rank all of a sudden.
They're unscheduled rank streams.
They'll most likely be on Twitch and not on YouTube.
But for scheduled stuff, I will do it on YouTube.
I'll be doing both.
I won't do multi-platform.
I don't like multi-streaming in general.
I don't like it.
I just wanted you guys to know.
So thank you all.
Thank you everybody.
We were all here.
Thank you everyone.
I'm so...
I'm very happy you guys all saw this.
And thank you for all the support and everything.
We have a concert on Saturday.
So I hope to see some of you guys there.
I'm going to call it here.
Because we do have another stream later today.
And I need to do work stuff now.
But thank you everybody.
We were all here.
Congrats on 800k.
Thank you.
Thank you the Akasupa.
Thank you all for the superchats and the akas and the members.
I'll be more mushy about the 800k on the stream tonight.
But thank you everybody.
As always, everyone stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
Get that blood flowing.
And you stay up for me head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
If you guys want to be a gamer like me.
And support me via other means.
I have Hyatt PC cases.
I have custom PC cases and custom keycaps.
So check out that link.
I pinned it in the description.
It's so cool.
It's pretty cool.
So check it out.
Look in the pinned message and chat.
And my mod can copy and paste that link.
Because I'm lazy right now.
Anyway guys.
Bye everybody.
Bye bye.
We're out of the circus.
Don't bust circus.
Goodbye.
I quit my clown job.